hallo leute wir sind heute in berlin mit
nina und abdul von german life style wir
besprechen weiter ein thema was von euch
schon oft angefragt wurde nämlich
bewerbungsgespräche in deutschland wir
fangen an mit einer kleinen szene mit
nina aller und abdul und da seht ihr wie
so ein bewerbungsgespräch idealer weise
abläuft oder auch nicht
los gehts los geht
[Musik]
guten tag haben es meinen sie müssten
frau bilder ist richtig schön helfer
haben dass sie das so kurzfristig
einrichten konnten haben sie denn im
hotel gefunden ja eh beschreibung war
sehr gut und sehr gut geholfen und ja
regisseur haben sie auch hier danke habe
gerade ganz frisch renoviert denken sie
doch bitte platz der fachhandel die
[Musik]
schau dir presse mich bewusst der guten
tag herr was sie sich ganz schön
verspätete aber meine assistentin hat
ihnen doch eine wegbeschreibung
geschickt der mich alle infos lesen aber
nach dem shop zeit ja herr vorhaben dann
würde ich sie bitten wir doch mal was
über sich ihre bewerbungsunterlagen habe
ich erhalten sehr strukturiert
lebenslauf hat mir schon mal gut
gefallen weil ich jetzt aber natürlich
gern noch mal aus ihrem mund hören
ich würde sie einmal durch die
wichtigsten stationen in meinem
lebenslauf hirn unterbrechen sie mich
gerne sollten sie fragen haben ich bin
den liebgewordenen da aufgewachsen in
2014 habe ich mein abitur gemacht mein
interesse galt schon immer den
naturwissenschaften ich habe mich dann
entschieden biochemie und regenerative
energie management aller uni kiel zu
studieren
da passt es keine bar hier platz haben
sie ja auch schon gefunden
und ja sie wollen bei uns arbeiten dann
erzählen sie mal was ich ja ich bin viel
cooler typ
ziemlich cool mathys freunde viel
unterwegs outen
ich kann mich gar nicht erinnern ihnen
das du angeboten zu haben
kein problem du kannst mir schon romig
dutzend ich bin ja nicht so berühmt
katzenbilder beiden facebook bekommen so
10 20 gleich nein so beruft mich auch
gar nicht gut dass man sich nicht
ja erfahren ich muss sagen sehr
beeindruckender lebenslauf michael
interessieren warum wollen sie gerne bei
uns arbeiten was interessiert sie
besonders an diesem job
das kann ich ihnen ganz leicht
beantworten ihre firma gilt ja nicht nur
als marktführer sondern auch als
innovativ und nachhaltig aufgestellt
diese filme kultur gefällt mir sehr gut
und finde ich zukunftsweisend und die
stelle als projektassistent finde ich
eine sehr super möglichkeit für mich in
den job einzusteigen und von der pike
auf zu lernen und ich glaube ich bringe
die nötigen fähigkeiten mit warum wollen
sie denn unbedingt bei uns arbeiten ja
meine freundin nervt mich die soll ja
geld verdienen
ich habe aber ehrlich gesagt keinen bock
so früh aufzustehen was bezahlst du
eigentlich
also ich glaube das ist nicht der
richtige zeitpunkt um an bargeld zu
sprechen
ja aber dafür ist immer der richtige
zeitpunkt ist hier sprach bollermann
[Musik]
ja also ich muss sagen das klingt als
würden sie sehr gut in unser team passen
eine frage habe ich aber natürlich noch
nennen sie mir noch mal ihre stärken und
ihre schwächen
ich würde pünktlichkeit und sorgfalt zu
meinen stärken zählen außerdem bin ich
flexibel und lernen schnell
ich hatte mich auch einen guten 10
player zu meinen schwächen ich sage mal
ich bin ein perfektionist
also ich lasse die sachen nebel sich die
100 prozent schaffe was mich manchmal
nervt aber ich arbeite noch daran
also ich würde ja sagen das ist
eigentlich auch eher eine stärke ja ok
sie brauchen also geld was können sie
denn wir sind ihre stärken ihre
schwächen stärke ich bin niemals stark
und ziemlich cool schwäche ich kenne das
wort gar nicht ich bin eher perfekt
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ich konnte mir einen
sehr guten eindruck von ihnen machen
vielen dank nochmal dass sie hier waren
haben sie dennoch fragen nicht jacobs
das habe ich tatsächlich das gehört
vielleicht nicht hierher aber ich habe
gehört dass ihre firma eine dependance
in schweden eröffnet was ich so
interessant findet können sie vielleicht
einen eindruck über den schwedischen
energiemarkt schildern
ich spreche auch übrigens perfekt
schwedisch
ich würde sagen wir melden uns haben sie
noch fragen
ja was eigentlich mit dem geld wie viel
bekommen
[Musik]
okay was wir melden uns nur können jetzt
gehen nina du hast ja tatsächlich in
deinem leben schon einige
bewerbungsgespräche geführt hast du dann
auch schon solche gespräche geführt wie
wir jetzt gerade in den szenen gesehen
haben
also so einzigen mit abkürzung glück
noch nie also das war etwas übertrieben
dass er etwas übertrieben ja aber du
hast uns ein paar tipps mitgebracht
worauf muss man achten wenn man in
deutschland zu einem bewerbungsgespräch
geht genau ich würde sagen es gibt so
drei faustregeln die ich hier mit auf
dem weg geben würde
das eine ist informiert euch immer sehr
sehr gut über das unternehmen bei dem
ihr euch bewerb schaut auf die
unternehmenswebseite schaut sucht in
news nach diesem unternehmen was gibt es
gerade aktuell der zweite tipp ist mut
und ehrlichkeit das ist schon ein
bisschen schwierig zu kombinieren mit
mut und ehrlichkeit meine ich seid mutig
mit dem was ihr könnt und traut euch
auch einiges zu mit ehrlichkeit meine
ich übertreibt nicht bei denen die ihr
nicht könnt seid da ganz ehrlich und
gebt auch zu wenn ihr was nicht könnt
oder gar nicht könnt und natürlich gerne
lernen wollt also bleibt positiv und
sogar dreieinhalb tipps mehr gerade und
der dritte tipp ist redet niemals
schlecht über ehemalige arbeitgeber
schulen universitäten professoren etc
also immer positiv bremer positiv
bleiben das macht einen guten eindruck
wenn man nicht schlecht über die
vergangenheit spricht
weil das hat mit dem neuen job ja gar
nichts zu tun und nena hat übrigens
extra für euch nochmal die tipps die sie
gerade genannt hat aber noch ein paar
weitere zusammengefasst in einem pdf für
euch was ich für euch vorbereitet habe
das findet ihr hier unten in der infobox
dann kann ihn gerne
danke auch an ampeln und aller aller ist
übrigens hinter der kamera
ihr seht ihr jetzt nicht aber er grinst
denn er hat diesmal alles richtig
er hat den job er hat den job bekommt
auf jeden fall könnt ihr jetzt auch noch
übungen machen zu dem vokabular das
könnt ihr einfach machen indem ihr ein
päckchen werdet dann findet der
interaktiven übungen mit vokabeln
grammatik und ihr könnt natürlich wie
immer easy gehrmann abonnieren und
unbedingt gs auch abonieren das könnte
zum beispiel hier machen wir freuen uns
wenn ihr nächste woche wieder da seid
und in der zwischenzeit guck mal was
abdul und allah und nina so bei gls
machen
richtig alle richtig ok dann gehen wir
jetzt langsam ganz langsam